we do have a present for you actually in
that present video from Miss Adrienne
bylines
are you open to playing Chanel again
absolutely I'm Chi Chi for luck yeah
yeah Raven as I have kept of great
relationship I love Raven to them I mean
it's literally - chiumbo bowls for life
and real life and we've actually gone to
my school around Vegas and have had good
times like that and we've had
conversations about life just how crazy
that would be if ever we did if it were
just like another something ever did
happen it would be amazing but you know
her a nice path we're kind of on the
same thing we want to make sure that
we're growing our careers further and
giving diving into different areas and
maybe it could happen one day but I mean
I started directing she's doing what
she's doing so there's a lot more things
to do in the future
[Applause]
where do you think though that they
would be if you guys were to do another
cheetah girls like where would bubbles
be please make my heart happy right
where would bubbles beat well since we
old now we would definitely be married
of some kind I think that she would be
overseas I wasn't in the installment for
India so we would have to come back and
resurrect the group entirety so I can't
answer that for you I cannot I'm sorry
okay lovely you had that reaction that
you did I love her hey you know like
friends family forever
you
[Music]